hi guys this is andrew from
trinscences.com so for those who are
watching my videos for the first time
i've been working as a professional
trainer for the past six years in
hong kong and i'm right now doing some
youtube videos where i show you
how i use technical analysis to build up
my scenarios and set up my trades
so if you guys want to know about all
the stuff and basically how to make
money on the markets
you are in the right place so in today's
video i want to
use idiot wave principle applied to amc
and show you guys all the different
financial data that we can use
to build up our view let's get into it
[Music]
alright guys so i did my last video on
amc
one two days ago so i'm using here the
market data of
uh wednesday night so maybe i'm gonna
have a bit of delay i'm sorry about that
i'm working so i don't have time
actually to do daily updates maybe one
day i will
so let me just quickly sum up the
situation here and we are going to do
some illiot
wave counting and try to see if our view
is actually fitting what we see on the
different data and we're going to see if
our view is actually
fitting the other information that we
get from the financial
data like the option open interest so
here let me very quickly sum up the
situation
for the idiot wave counting on the
longer term so let's start on the daily
time frame
we have this strong crazy move up here
you can call it a short squeeze to me it
was not a short squeeze because the
short interest didn't decrease
that much during this period all right i
can show you guys this
okay amc showed interest so here you can
see
that this crazy rally occurred between
the 15th and the 29th of jan
and the short interest in million of
shares moved
from 45 million to 37 million so only
seven million shares were brought back
by shorts during this time so this
is not enough to create a short squeeze
seven million shares on amc is
not enough and this is the reason why to
me this was
not a short squeeze but just a very
strong
rally so we had the strong move up then
here we have our abc correction
totally makes sense typical abc
the c wave a bit longer you know this
is something that i often see it's not
what we
you would see in the books you know they
usually might like to you know show you
like perfect abcs like this all right
the reality is that
you sometimes have some very strong
and intense a b waves and then the c
wave is a bit
longer but deeper this is something that
we are used to seeing
when we do idiot wave counting
quite often so here then we
are looking for another one two three
four five guys
so i put this one in blue i put this one
in blue
and i use all my technical analysis to
actually
help me to find the levels of this
one two three four five and we have been
in this second corrective wave for the
past
month between the 18th of march
till the 15th of april roughly where we
had this breakout that
i gave you guys we've been in the second
wave so right now
we are in the third wave of the third
wave
of the third wave so let me zoom in a
little bit
then i'm going to tell you why the third
wave is going here and why the fifth
wave
is going here but first let me zoom in
okay so once again this abc is complete
because we broke
here the trend line really tested it
which is confirming us that we were
actually checking the right
thing the right trend line we have all
our bullish divergences that
i told you guys about i'm not going to
go through this
here again then here we have our
beautiful
so for to see this one you need to go on
an hourly time frame
so here we have a beautiful one two
three four five that is complete
we corrected with a nice abc
and i was telling you guys in my
previous video that
you know 1060 10 50 would be the support
and we have one more at 10 20. so the c
wave could go to 10 20. it could still
be valid and especially here we have
this 200 p moving average coming here so
i'm expecting the 200 moving average on
the hourly time frame to hold the price
here i think this is going to act as a
strong support
and i'm expecting the wave counting to
keep developing on the upside
so here we probably gonna correct
until the 29th of april maximum i told
you guys in the video i posted a few
days ago i'm expecting a bullish run
here
so i'm not sure if we had it or not when
i'm actually posting this one
but i can give you my scenario so one
two three four five
abc then here so this is a one
this is a two you're gonna have a three
something like here
okay three four five this would be the
typical
case so once again this is very
you know a precise scenario so the
probability it would be
100 correct is quite low
but you know this is what i would see
amc doing
in a typical situation then a correction
so here we have a zigzag
so here i would expect a flat correction
for something like this okay
a bit the same length in time you know
sometimes the second wave is shorter so
the fourth wave are usually a bit longer
it could be also a triangle so we would
analyze what is happening here
and then the fifth wave going here guys
so why here because it's the maximum
level that we had
on our fifth wave of the first move up
so this is the reason why i think that
the third wave might go here
then we would correct so once again we
had here an abc
so in a zigzag pattern so i'm expecting
here
once again to have a longer correction
as this one maybe even longer maybe it
would be something like this guys and
in this fourth wave we we usually remain
above this one
so we would stay above 15 probably if we
go there
and we would also usually correct till
the top of the third wave of the
preceding wave so it's a bit complicated
to process but basically it would be
around here so this is actually maybe
giving me
maybe something like this so i would
have this at the same level
okay
so this is something that would make
sense so let's see what is happening
here guys
but even if we go higher we will
ultimately come back
here to get some more liquidity before
making the last
strong move up that would then go to 35.
now why my scenario is that bullish so
of course you know i gave you here a lot
of
information that is just coming from
what i usually see that is coming from
the idiot wave
principles but i also use some financial
data
like open interest to see if the market
is going in the upside direction or not
let me show you this
so for those who remember i showed you
guys in my previous video
that so amc was a bit lower
okay and here go check it out
yes this is the total short interest so
maximum
short synthetic short interest if all
the call options are in the money so for
example if amc goes to 100
then the synthetic shot would be 15
which is this number
and go check the video i did last week
guys this was 12
so it grew by three percent of the total
number of shares
which is a lot so basically 0.03
times a share so now it's 11
times the total number of shares
so guys it's 100 million usd all right
so 100 million usd more coming on the
synthetic short market
and it's not even this number that is
you know
telling me that we are bullish it's just
that i can see it
growing i can see it going uh in the
same direction for
quite a long time and the 4d strike here
is still quite
high in terms of number of shares and we
also have all these
strikes around like between 10 and
20 you can see here those are the levels
where i have the more the more options
so this
is going to create some gamma this is
going to create some bullish momentum
once again guys the typical so if we go
to 12 for example this is growing you
can see we're going to six percent
and once again guys the typical one is
for example like apple the typical
synthetic short interest is around 0.6
so when you have something close to like
5 10
and that can go up to 15 this is giving
you the information that we are bullish
and last thing i wanted to show you guys
okay people are wondering why nc
corrected
for me you know the second wave of
idiots that i showed you here
that we just had recently
we lost around 12 compared to the
highest level we had
on the 27th of april and the level we
have
on the 28th of april at the closing
market and
analysts always try to understand for me
it's just like you know
healthy correction but there is a rumor
that amc would finally emit some shares
so ymc stock is down on wednesday
and they're saying that basically the
company needs to
pay some debt and that they're gonna
maybe emit
43 million additional shares so which is
around 10
dilution so i'm not sure if they did it
or not the mcco
said he would not uh emit more shares
actually maybe they do
this is not so important guys you know
this is not a market
movers to me what would be important is
that we're gonna have
on the 6th of may the results the
earnings
first quarter earnings announced by amc
so we're not expecting something very
huge here but this could be
catalyzer that helps the price action to
go higher
so let me show you guys my counting
again
so i'm taking a lot of frizz guys
because i'm giving you you know
my view very detailed that is you know
in a very long time so let's see let's
see if things go
in the direction i'm expecting let's see
if actually this scenario is confirming
or not
once again this is very bullish we would
need some volumes to kick in
in order to see this scenario happening
but for now i have all the signals that
are pointing in the same
direction if i have different signals
like some you know bearish divergences
or if i see the volatility of options
going lower or if i see some important
levels that are not holding i would of
course let you
know so i hope you guys enjoyed this
video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything new
and stay close to show i see you guys